think that's kind of where the future of
media is going right or earliest night
in the future I mean it's basically
happening now where we used to see
companies build products and then go try
to find their customers or find the
distribution and they would test a bunch
of stuff on the distribution side after
the product was built now what you're
seeing actually is the reverse where
people go good at the distribution they
build out big audiences and then they
figure out what product I want to sell
this audience or the kind of this these
eyeballs right maybe talk a little bit
about how you think about that that
shift and how that's changed what you
were doing on a day to day basis the
number one thing I spent time on at heyo
was trying to convince affiliates that
our 30% cut we would give them is worth
him like emailing our list about us and
I hated it
because I was doing it over and over and
over but what these affiliates have done
is they built great distribution
channels in the front of a blog you know
from an email newsletter whatever
YouTube Twitter you name it and say know
what the what's much smarter to build
for my next thing this was in 2015 is
dominant you like pick a space that you
love right and then figure out a build a
dominant distribution channel in that
space and then based off you know
reviews on iTunes or feedback you're
getting your email replies you'll you'll
fall most fall into products you can
sell to that space that add them value
but what's way more viable than any
product in my opinion again is the
distribution channel it's the reason
like we've launched I can't there's not
one in distance here but we've launched
like a magazine for my focus now is a
software entrepreneurs we launched a
magazine if the book we have the podcast
and all these things allow me to now
sell my main thing which is debt into
SAS companies but the distribution has
to come first I think yes so talk about
that a little bit more right is as you
started to build the distribution you
started with the podcast first yet the
book and then maybe walk us through just
kind of sequentially what you did and
why you made each one of those decisions
was it something that you learned from
kind of the past work you were doing or
was it somebody came to you like help us
understand kind of what drove each one
of those decisions so the pot I started
the podcast I sell the company in 2015
August of 2015 I launched the podcast
biggest question first off like besides
like the basic stuff like what
microphone you use right by the way I
have like
home-studio that costing about 30 bucks
at least it's quick to put together the
second thing is though how do you start
getting big guests on the show and so
what I start because I had no show so
what I did is I email at about a hundred
people I wanted on the show and
basically said hey I'd love to do an
episode with you we will have a million
downloads buddy
bye-bye winter basically we're launching
August and so what they heard was we
have a million downloads but I said we
will I have the most we will have a
million up that confidence allowed me to
get about 10 verse and those interviews
actually done so I had 50 pre-recorded
before I launched the show and then I
used a little bit of kind of social
dynamic I guess you'd call it to get
these people to market the show so what
I said is hey guys I'm picking 10 of
these to go live on with on launch day
it'll be the 10 of you that first agreed
to email your list about your episode
and so I basically had 10 people sending
out emails that about three million
emails going out on day one for the
podcast which just shot us way up number
one of the ranking you take that screen
shot to get new guests and so I just
kind of I call it elephant bumping
you're just connecting and you're using
other people's audiences and delivering
value than to your audience and so that
bumping got us to more than a million
downloads by that winter today the show
has more than 10 million and and I look
at you know I look at the podcast almost
probably I think maybe how Native
Americans looked at corn right it's it
it's a thing to trade it's like
bartering it's like you know I have each
week seven inventories of corn one
interview a day and you can like trade
this for all kinds of things whether
it's a keynote at the person's event
that you're interviewing or or email
boxes there I mean there's so many
things you can trade for but I use it to
trade and then that you know built into
the book the book then built into the
magazine which we now you know we
launched the magazine it now ships
monthly to about 10,000 CEOs and they
all pay for it's 29 bucks an issue so
maybe the most expensive magazine out
there these days and then from that I
listen to what entrepreneurs wanted and
a lot of them said Nathan we don't want
to get diluted from VCS
we really like art we have a great
business with Health Unit
why can't we get debt debt basically
cheap debt so I said oh my gosh that's
where I should start doing I should
start loaning money to SAS companies can
keep their companies as they scale and
that's what I'm doing today I think
we'll deploy probably anywhere between
15 and 20 million in capital and
disasters over the next 12 months as
debt